potentially if subscribers are
subscribing for different reasons it's
good to divide up the content but I'm
going to actually challenge your
question with a question Corey why even
create multiple channels any parents in
the house it's hard enough to have one
kid try having two and so you have two
YouTube channels you're just putting
that much more pressure stress to try to
grow both of them it's fine but what I
would challenge everybody listening and
watching this focus on one thing and get
that one thing producing for you rather
than trying to start a couple things
it's hard enough to run one business
while you're trying to run three
especially if the one business isn't
producing cash flow and margin I would
even argue like legit there's no exact
math but I would argue if your one
business isn't paying you six figures
yet or multiple six figures yet net you
shouldn't start a second business do we
know the difference between gross and
that not earning six figures a year but
actually you keep after all your
expenses and contractors and software
and everything else so if you haven't
got your one I would say this if you
haven't got one YouTube channel to
generating six figures for you yet why
are you starting another YouTube channel